le quartier de syndicats sous couvre-feu
ce matin
interdiction de circuler pour les
quelques civils restés ici les autorités
de quart qu'ils craignent des frappes
massives russe en cette date symbolique
il y a 6 bon un jour pour jour ses
habitants vivaient les premières heures
de l'invasion ces quatre personnes sont
les seuls à être resté dans cet immeuble
plus aucune famille
sirène d'alarmé
détonation dans le ciel mais ses tirs
d'artillerie russe ne les intimide plus
on ne peut pas peur c'est fini ça donc
fermer fenêtres on descend ici c'est
moins dangereux on s'assoit et on est
comme une famille on s'aide
pas d'eau dont les étages seulement au
premier les journées sont donc rythmé
par ces corvées
bien sûr si on n'a pas de chauffage cet
hiver on devra partir on ne pourra pas
rester malheureusement
l'immeuble a été touché par un tir
d'obus
début mars une partie du troisième étage
est détruite mais le reste est encore de
ces deux femmes ont leurs grands enfants
à l'abri dans l'est du pays ou à
l'étranger
elle habite au 14e et 16e étage c'est
une épreuve de vitré si
c'est dur mais maintenant je suis
habituée ça fait des mois que je fais ça
cette femme de 83 ans titube de fatigue
après avoir monté les étages
mais quand sa voisine elle est bien
décidée à rester chez elle
à l'extérieur ces ruines elle témoigne
de ces mois de cauchemar vécu par les
civils et c'est tout un symbole ce métro
qui était bondé pendant des semaines il
ne l'est plus aujourd'hui
mais quelques dizaines d'habitants
dorment encore ici la nuit et ne sortent
que le ch en cours
c'est le seul endroit où je me sens en
sécurité à la maison dans notre immeuble
nous n'avons pas d'abris alors on y va
dans la journée mais on dort ici
pour l'instant plusieurs bombardements
sur toute l'ukraine cette nuit et ce
matin plus que d'habitude
le couvre feu est respecté